what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
i have a special announcement today but
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
while you're at it follow my instagram
it's just pearly things with the z
um i post a lot of fitness stuff on
there so if you're interested in that
go follow my instagram okay that's my
all my plugs i'm done
i swear okay so the announcement is
i have been blackpilled um i want you
guys to know that not all of these
ideas are my own um i came across the
channel wheat waffles
um a phenomenal channel if you guys
got time their link is in the
description but
for real i think this channel is about
to blow up because i've never seen
dating advice
that makes more sense so
what is the black pill basically it
means that everything starts with
looks and a lot of red pill guys are
gonna say no to this
but what i'm saying makes a lot of sense
to me
anyways so let's say you're born looking
like this i would say
he's below a four so these are like
below average
um so oh and for guys it's your face and
your height those are the two
factors that determine like your league
so
below five six below a four in the face
next is we got mr average
so average looking between five seven
and five eleven
in height and a four to five in looks
next we got um
mr slightly above average so
slightly above average five seven to
five eleven in
height and a five to seven it looks and
these can be interchangeable like
maybe he's tall but doesn't have
you know as good of a face or maybe he
is
short but has a really good face just
you know either or okay
then we got like the chat you guys call
them chads so the chads of the world
and these are the models basically six
foot plus
um eight and above it looks and again
these are like
interchangeable you know maybe
he is on the shorter set but it doesn't
matter
okay model status okay and so
what basically so you you're born into
your league
and this is like i think of it as like
division one division two and division
three
and you can maybe go up
one division or one league but you can't
jump
leagues it's just not possible so these
are the adjustables
fitness income game being funny your
common interest being smart
so let's say you're born you're this guy
and you
want to get a girlfriend if you're below
four that's going to be
exceptionally hard but in order to
improve your chances
you work on these things and then maybe
you can get an
average looking girl but this is why i
think that not all dating advice is good
dating advice for everyone because
if you're this guy and let's say you're
one or two
and you literally cannot get into the
next league
unless you want to like be by yourself
forever i'm sorry guys
you might have to date a single mother
you might have to date a girl that's
overweight it just
really depends on your league telling
the chads don't settle don't settle
sure sure that's great advice but
what if you're over here okay
um next we're going to mr
average and by the way these heights
aren't like there's no
real data behind it this is just what i
would guess
it is okay so we got mr average so i put
them five seven to five eleven in height
four to five in looks um
so this guy could maybe get a girl
on the slightly above average level if
he works on this stuff
and the concept's pretty much the same
so any of these
guys can work on this stuff and go one
maybe two if he's the extreme like if
he's a billionaire
right or a millionaire but most people
they're not the extremes right it's a
very small percentage of people
that change their income so much that
they're a millionaire a billionaire
does that make sense guys so i'm just
talking for more everyday people maybe
you
increase your income by 20k increase
your gain by like 10
20 that's still good but i think we
think a lot in extremes but i'm still
gonna give some extreme examples
just because they're easier to come to
mind we got
mark zuckerberg so he's five seven and
facially i would put him at like four
maybe a five
so average
right he's like pretty much mr average
his wife what does she look like
she's cute i'd give her a six
exactly what i said and i'm not saying
there aren't
examples where like the guy's super old
or super ugly
and the girls with him but i think most
people on some level
want someone that like they can at least
convince themselves
is with them for them and it
enjoys qualities about them not just
what they have so
while you know you can do that
um the second the money's gone they go
okay next we got melinda so a lot of
this is an example right where he's not
attractive whatever
but guys trump is 6'3 so that still puts
him in the chad level height
now facially i probably put him like
average maybe but he's still
chad level height so i would that
averages out to slightly above average
and what did i say with this stuff you
can get
a league above you so that would be
melinda right super bottled
bill and melinda gates so again
especially if you look at young pictures
of bill
five four maybe average height but on
the high end right
but melinda she's like she's i mean
she's older now but you can tell like
she's cute
but you know
not it's not like supermodel level i
mean who knows what he'll date next i
don't know but
just my two cents okay so now we have
the girl scale
so i mean a girl version of this too so
there's the girls that are for or below
and looks i know this is extreme but it
was really hard to find like an ugly
person that was just like a model on the
internet
because it was it would always be like
attractive models trying to look ugly so
it didn't even
height doesn't really play a factor um i
think it plays more of a factor in like
what women are attracted to but like i
don't think
most guys care that much about a girl's
height
okay so then we got a four to five face
slightly above average and you know i'm
not saying these girls are like the
epitome of
what it would be it's just what i put
them as
but six to seven face like this girl's
cute just got a big forehead whatever
um and then the eight plus supermodels
so then these are girl adjustable
so being feminine um a good body
friendly super nice common interest
compatible
i think guys care about hard workers
but i could be wrong it's just you know
and again i think guys care more about
common interests
than people really give it credit for in
the menosphere oh and a low body count
that too so
oh shoot this next slide is i'm supposed
to come back to it so just pretend you
didn't see it pretend you didn't see it
but it's basically the same thing so a
girl that's a four to five
she could like let's say she's a five
she could maybe get like a seven
if she has some of these things
um and why i say
get this is this is what i hate about
the man of sphere
they they say act like dates attention
and sex is what girls want and i'm sure
like
on some level they do but girls want
relationships so
guys don't access access to sex girls
want access to relationships and to get
married just
in general so you have to look at that
as like the prize not
oh a girl gets more dates than a guy or
whatever because it doesn't matter if
he's not going to marry or date her
so this is what i mean like a girl
that's a five could maybe if she worked
really hard on all these things
get a seven right um same with the girl
that's a seven
she works really hard on that thing
these things she can maybe
get a ten but there's nothing you can do
as a girl or really a guy
to go up in like your league that much
we're gonna come back to that but these
are just some of the examples that i
thought of so
again melinda um i would
put her it's hard to tell she's a little
older but
maybe like a five
six maybe maybe she's probably six when
she was younger um
so and bill gates is a billionaire
um you know average looking billionaire
but still billionaire so she's
i'm sure they've like i know she was ivy
league so assuming she's smart common
interest
these are harder to do for women because
i don't you you can't
see the like there's no way to really
measure the character traits or
the traits that people look for okay but
we're gonna go back to this this is the
other point i disagree with do men age
like fine right
why like fine wine um yes if you are
already tall and good looking i don't
think the majority of men
um are though that's like a small
percentage so kevin samuels will say
that a lot but i'm like
he's 6'4 and he looks young he's the
exception he's not the rule
also if you stay in shape most people
don't stay in shape most
dads have like beer bot like bellies and
stuff
um yes if you don't bald most guys start
balding
and after 40 i would say now um
i i played on a lot of sports teams with
pretty attractive women like i was in
three different sports teams in college
so these are girls like
between the ages of like 19 or 18
actually
to 23 so like prime age and none of them
dated that much older like definitely
not over 40.
i don't even i think there's maybe one
girl on the team that dated over 30.
um so yeah just my two cents that i
disagree with but let me know in the
comments if you guys
agree or you disagree don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell
and go subscribe to wheatwaffles because
i just binged watch
binge watched all this stuff and i
thought it was so entertaining
so yeah i will talk to you guys next
time